so he's my B so I'm going to
differentiate now I'm in a position
racking different [ __ ] so what's the do
okay now can you see why I was telling
you before changing from these numbers
to these numbers see better but actually
now remember I want possible tiny points
right so my first two video let n equal
0 alright now when you take that you can
divide through by 4 gives you this okay
it's just according so I'm expecting two
solutions to this okay so can you go
into your formula right so X is equal to
go from memory this is going to be what
on
I think it's 25 plus or minus five seven
on three is this off stride going
through a quadratic formula and
simplified the just gonna didn't take it
all out now here's the important thing
okay two stationary points now be
careful we would just make a big deal
about the restrictions okay so we need
to check do these sit in the within the
restrictions right so what are these
actually equals okay so 25 plus actually
would like a number it's all Union them
up one decimal places
am I gonna get two tears in my eyes
12.7 roughly and I think what's the
other one's slightly three-point yeah
okay all right now you can see the
restrictions are going to knock one out
but I really like this is an example
because people tend to default when they
see a quadratic equation right into
solutions people tend to default to get
rid of the negative one okay because
usually sorry this smaller one because
usually it's negative and links can't be
negative okay but in this case it's the
biggest solution which is invalid okay
so you'd say but quit your restriction
right
so therefore X is and I'll take a - 125
- 5 root 7 on three only ok now because
this is just really awkward let's just
proceed for the rest of the question
finding the dimensions or volume let's
just use my decimal place so I'm gonna
get my dimensions in second but again I
have to show that this is on a minimum
and it's the min right so what am I
gonna do okay I'm gonna go he's the
first derivative right so that implies
the second derivative which is 24x minus
200 ok so I'm gonna have to take this
value right well 3.9 a plug it in okay
and you're getting here well look at
that 24 times like about further so it's
about 96 minus 200 so this is negative
that's what makes it concave down so
yeah I ran off so that I could know what
are these are and do they fit within the
domain because I have no idea what these
are alright so having done that then I
need to go and go through the fact that
this is a polynomial so don't
beauties after going through that
improving okay
I wanted the dimensions and the volume
okay so what are the dimensions X by 20
ways to X so 3 point 9 by 20 minus 7
point 8 20 minus 7 point a to point to
my okay so there are out dimensions I
suppose I shouldn't put centimeters okay
okay
okay the estimation started to die a
little bit okay so behavior 1,000
squeezers this sound about right
so I 1000 that's about a leader isn't it
just a bit yeah obviously cuz what that
which actually does make kind of sense
right can we actually cut this out it's
a three point nine that's about four
centimeters right which is actually
close to what I ended up doing for you
guys we're now just mean you know so can
you see how accurately I'm cutting three
point nine centimeters this is the best
the best diagram ever if I fold this
right it should be close to like well
one leaders like you know it kind of
milk yeah
yeah I'll pass I think they assumed
material zero yes well it should be it
should be this right yeah that looks
like about 12 points to across yeah it
looks like that looks about 12 points
well it's a bit off I think these are
bigger than 3.9 that's the problem but